[Music]
senior team of the year sponsored by
Devon FA Ashmore hockey club Ashmore
hockey club's great season ended
fantastically when they won the men's
team of the Year award from England
hockey for their performances as a club
the team began in the bottom tier in
2003 but won the championship last year
and for the first time in their history
had been promoted to the top tier of the
regional outdoor league it's been a
truly amazing season for their first
team and to capital Sam Taylor who came
through the club's junior ranks has been
picked for the England under 18 boys
squad and Alfie Finney a national junior
who started with the club at its
inception in 2003 as an 8 year old
recently represented Wales at the Gold
Coast 2018 Commonwealth Games Buckland
Athletic FC ladies first team having
only formed three years ago
Buckland Athletic ladies have secured
three consecutive league titles to get
promoted into the FA Women's National
League a fantastic achievement for a
team from the local area last season saw
Buckland win all 22 games scoring 132
goals and only conceding seven on their
way to dominating the league on top of
this they reached the FA Cup second
round defeating teams two leagues above
the fantastic achievements are down to
the hard work and dedication of everyone
at the club with the aim to continue the
success and progression both on and off
the pitch
decoy BMX club for only the second time
in their history decoy BMX club has
finished top of the regional race Series
standings decoy took the lead after
round 2 and have maintained it right
through to the end seeing off the likes
of city based clubs such as Exeter
Bristol and buff the club is also
standing at very proud 15th out of 61 in
the National standings the highest
ranked club from the southwest region
decoy continues year-on-year to grow in
both its size and success with the club
taking largest number of riders in the
southwest region to the British
Championships the club also had four
qualifying riders make the trip over to
Azerbaijan this year to represent Team
GB at the world championships
[Music]
you